um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello i'm shania peart i am from
bayshore new york and i am a senior
mathematics major at villanova
university
hi my name is alex isaac i am currently
a visiting scholar at the university of
illinois in urbana-champaign
within the coordinator science
laboratory and the research that i do is
within the intersection of visual arts
creativity and ai artificial
intelligence i recently graduated in
mathematics and studio arts from the
college of worcester in western ohio so
i originally came to villanova
as a chemistry major and i spent
about three semesters as a chemistry
major before i realized that uh the most
attracting part about chemistry for me
was the mathematics and
as i was getting up into classes that
didn't involve math i started to enjoy
them less and so i decided to switch my
major
in the second semester of my sophomore
year to mathematics eventually during my
junior year i
took some
courses that were focused more on pure
mathematics like i took some i mean all
of my courses have been more pure
mathematics but i took some more like i
took number theory and abstract algebra
and advanced calculus and
i really enjoyed the proofs
and learning the pure mathematical
concepts and that's when i decided that
i'd really like to pursue
a graduate degree in pure mathematics
and
um
my experience with the
david harold blackwell summer research
institute really helped to just
solidify that decision because i got to
get a hands-on experience in what it's
like to be a pure mathematics
research mathematician the way i learned
about the blackwell institute was
actually
in my pursuit of finding my post-grad
trajectory upon the completion of my
junior year i knew upon graduation that
i did not seek to get into
an industry role nor a phd because i
still had i needed time for critical
thinking about what i wanted to do what
i wanted to study and so i wanted to
provide myself with
a post back that will allow me to
conduct research within my interests and
at the same time
think about what i want to do my program
mentor was dr wilford
gengbo from ucla and
my project was finite dimensional
non-commutative
optimal mass transport the topic is what
professor gangbo's primary research is
in is in optimal mass transport theory
and so that's how i came upon i never
heard of it before
the whole premise of the problem is
trying to
transport a mass or mass use multiple
mass units in
um the most efficient way my mentor at
the institute was um
professor talk coleman and it was
a very
i enjoyed my experience very much i
think it was absolutely priceless to
begin with
the project that we worked on so
essentially i've always been within i've
always known that i wanted to expand my
knowledge of mathematics within an
applied sense and as an artist as well
the way i sought to combine this
together currently is through ai art for
instance but i knew i wanted to pivot
because professor todd coleman is in
bioengineering i thought well i could
pivot to within biology it's these leaps
of faith that you take and uh that get
you to the places where you never know
you can end up and it was absolutely
beautiful and the project we worked on
was in a sense um
so there was um
we had data on a patient a diabetic
patient's blood glucose levels as well
as their stomach activity and there was
some sort of
there was a relationship that was
noticed in a sense where your blood
glucose and your stomach activity are
inversely related and so there was a a
relationship that we noticed and we
wanted to model that and we created an
uh utter regressive model and there was
a relationship that we were able to find
however it wasn't significant which is
understandable because our data needed a
larger larger context about what foods
the patient was in taking at what time
and
however it was good because we were able
to create a stepping stone
towards this this thinking and also
understand the data not only from or
what was observed in the data not only
from a
data point of view but also from a
theoretical point of view because the
model we creating goes down to the
fundamentals of linear algebra which is
the fundamentals of mathematics and
applied mathematics the program really
just introduced me to what it was like
to do mathematics research in pure
mathematics i originally have only
experience with
mathematics in the sense of chemistry
and computational chemistry and so it
was nice to
experience research from a purely
mathematics
standpoint which is something i was
interested in studying in grad school
and
it was also helpful because it was more
of like
um
getting to learn from
professor gangbo and my um ta mohit
vancil who's a phd student at ucla they
were very helpful in sort of giving me
like a
quick uh brief
introduction to real analysis
or complex analysis which was helpful
and will be helpful next semester when i
take the course
so my research interest since then have
uh gradually changed mainly because
now i i'm more open to pivoting
pivoting in terms of not restricting
myself with the mathematics and arts but
also pivoting to other sense uh other
fields
i have now i'm more open to to fields
such as the environmental sciences
because i do find myself as a
sustainable and holistic person and so
it's been very eye opening towards the
possibilities of what i can even go to
and pursue within my
studies within my phd and and ask myself
the different collaborations that i can
also undertake while i'm conducting
a phd in the near future
i found this program was very unique i'm
sure there's probably some more like
this but
at least in my search this program
seemed very unique because it was
geared towards um specifically towards
african american mathematicians or black
mathematicians and
you know there are other minority
mathematicians in the program but i
think that that was
um
something that made this program stand
out to me as opposed to other reu's
which i did apply to because
it was focused on
increasing
black mathematicians and the amount of
black phd mathematicians in the world
which is something that i'm really
passionate about and
considering i go to a school where
there's not many black mathematicians
as professors or as students and
it was nice to get a chance to learn
from
professors who
shared similar experiences with me and
looked like me coming out of it there
was a change in trajectory which has
occurred and which i am grateful for
because it has opened my mind towards
this year that i'm taking to critically
think about my trajectory and so it has
absolutely impacted me but more so than
their project also interacting with the
professors and interacting with them on
a human basis because we would meet for
lunch
virtually and during those moments we
would ask questions and i got to know
them as human beings and ask the
questions that i wanted to or even know
how to interact with with professors as
as
other humans going through you know
their life experiences and there wasn't
a little level of hierarchy that limited
whether
a question was applicable or not and it
was just holistic understanding i was
able to gain about
how
what it would mean to pursue a phd in
mathematics well overall hearing their
experiences i think if anything i saw a
lot of ambition and i believe that if
anything one take away of like fat take
away a word it would be ambitious
because they are very ambitious and it
just gives you a drive i would say and
so i would say it was a absolutely
amazing experience and i wouldn't change
it for anything and i am sure and
certain that it's going to be a program
that will impact me
i would say my like for math or love for
math really began at villanova with the
math professors that i've had here as a
chemistry major i had to take calculus
one and two and my professor here at del
nova i had vikram command dr vikram
kamat for
calculus one and he was very encouraging
and helpful
and
just
allowed me to build up my confidence in
my mathematical abilities which
continued through
um my classes and then i saw that sort
of pour into my chemistry classes with
the math is that i was getting more
confident with math and it was becoming
something that i could really
see myself doing and enjoy doing and so
that's how i
sort of became a math lover
so i think that cultivating
students especially minority students or
black students who
want are interested or want to be
interested in math really starts in the
younger years in elementary and in those
level courses
and i think it really
depends on the profi the teachers
realizing that a lot of students um of
color a lot of black students don't come
from family backgrounds where they are
getting homework help and so when
they're learning math in class that is
the first time they're seeing it and
it's the only experience that they are
going to have with it for a lot of
students not true for all but true for
many that you know their parents at
least for me i'm a first generation
american and a first generation college
student so i didn't have parents who
went to college
um
and they didn't go to school in america
so it was very hard to get homework help
and i was basically doing everything on
my own when i wasn't in class
and
so i think it's important to know that
not every student is receiving the same
help at home and so it can be
discouraging when other students who
have parents who can help them
understand math or take them to math
tutoring like i could never go to
tutoring because my mother had to work
all of the time and so i could only
my only hope was myself and so
that's true for a lot of black students
is that
even as they go into college that you
know some of them they have to work to
support themselves because they come
from single-parent households or because
they just come from lower income
households
and so they have to work to support
themselves and they can't really focus
as heavily as they would as their white
counterparts or
more affluent counterparts on
math or on their homework or on anything
and so it's very discouraging especially
because math is so
you have to get it like you just have to
like there's the right answer and it's
not i mean as you grow go into the
higher level courses of course there's
more
ways to do proofs and things but when
you're really in like calculus there's
really just one answer and
a lot of students don't have enough time
to devote to that which makes them shy
away from that they think that math is
scary because they don't have
as much time to devote to something that
doesn't come naturally for a lot of
people like i don't know for me math
didn't come naturally i had to work at
it and so i would say just having more
resources in general that
are targeted at
um
helping these students to
get a more background in math outside of
the classroom or even in the classroom
just having like for me having a teacher
that encouraged me and i guess you know
not paid me special attention but
complimented me when i did well
in my in math helped me to
want to continue to do it
as for my career goals um
i do know
much more in the future there
there is a
uh a sense in me that i i do want to
become a farmer and a farmer because i'm
from i'm from ethiopia and
growing up when my mother always said
well it this isn't amharic and it says
which means don't forget the farmer who
taught you that teaching themselves
because of the the way the economy is
set up and i think coming to college i
came to the middle of
ohio in the midwest and i saw how
farming is actually
was a respected field in many senses and
i think i've always seen it that way but
going back to ethiopia and becoming a
farmer was something that i've always
wanted to and here i was able to see a
different perspective and in order to
become a farmer i think because it's
very much ingrained within nature
i want to develop these quantitative
skills or qualitative skills to
eventually allow me to have these
the knowledge to have a farm not only in
a sense of production but also to bring
myself closer
bring myself closer to nature and to
integrate my knowledge and integrate my
knowledge for the greater good of a
larger community
after graduate school i'm hoping to do
research um
i haven't decided if i want to stay in
academia and do
and be a professor and also do research
or if i want to branch out but
the goal is to do research
[Music]
you